il ya des plats qu'ils ne font pas
l'unanimité et qu'on doit apprivoiser
avant d'y goûter comme le haggis
heureusement avec des écossais aussi
charmant on va se laisser tenter par
leur plat national
bienvenue au glengarry highland games le
temps d'une fin de semaine le petit
village de maxville en ontario se
transforme quelques trente mille
visiteurs se prêtent au jeu écossais et
vibre au son des cornemuses dont
l'ancien président des jeux gold white
vous avez les personnes qui aiment
d'économie
le haggis le plat national des écossais
est à l'honneur ce sont là culturel pour
nos grands bals nos grands super
écossais
tel que le commandent la tradition
joueur de cornemuse porteurs de sabre et
le scotch ouvre le chemin pour la
cérémonie du haggis une véritable
religion
il faut essayer la guerre juste petits
morceaux
avec
grâce et c'est peut-être un morceau plus
là
vous
musquin
cheron la team prépare depuis des
semaines plus de 15 kilos de haggis pour
le bal du tartan
arrête
yorkais
il est temps de les livrer à la salle où
quelque 180 convives attendent avec
impatience de lui faire honneur
il faut que vous m'expliquiez stuart là
j'ai l'impression que la glisse c'est
quasiment une religion en écosse
c'est une façon d'utiliser tout un
animaux pas juste pour les clubs prime
car manche séjour c'est un vrai pas
vraiment qu'un baigneur et le loup
l'histoire dira glisse est aussi
mystérieuse que celle du monstre du loch
ness les premières recettes écrites
remonte au 15e siècle le haggis fait
partie de la grande famille des
saucisses un moyen efficace de
conservation le chef tué abrams du
restaurant l'ambroisie est un passionné
du haggis seulement qu'il s'en parle de
sa cause de les aiguiller les apps à la
fois l'union est aux mains d'un mouton
c'est pas quelque chose avant chaque
jour mais assez bien pas pris avec goût
montrez moi qu'est ce qu'on a comme
ingrédient pour préparer les vagues s
être le poumon toutes les sortes de
morceaux de viande d'animaux les dents
de nice et la tête de consolation pour
utiliser toute l'inde mots de néac eu
des choses en ce sens il fait d'abord
revenir les abats qui sont ensuite
bouillie pendant une heure
parfait c'est bien
ça sent bon
ce sont deux fois ouais
ça c'est no 1 guignen maîtres dans la
soirée
l'audience
est maintenant
ça sent déjà bon
les épices on avait le mar si le mas si
c'est quoi c'est comme les coquilles de
muscade une noix de muscade c'est un
crépi qui au tournoi qui en vie et un
hollande comme support muscade c'est
intense très intense c'est bon sens ça
c'est le premier goût veut goûter dans
laquelle on ajoute de l'avoine conte
classique pour donner de la texture aux
mélanges et un peu de liquide de cuisson
saussez le bouillon
leur mettant des vins de vue cette
texture là c'est commencer mouiller et
se collent les bulldogs en prennent beau
à force d'arguments
qu'il bouillot un petit morceau partie
montceau un voeu fournisseurs jusque
c'est bien de serré mais pas trop parce
que peut-être fait exploser dans le
rapport ok ça c'est un autre petit à gaz
produit parfait
ému le haggis et soigneusement ficelé et
quid de nouveau cette fois ci à la
vapeur le haggis a mauvaise réputation
et pourtant
c'était bien le cas ci mais il est des
personnes qui aiment la guerre ou
d'états ne s'est pas des personnes dans
le milieu ok leur guise pour moi c'est
comme du pâté ses bons voeux votre super
de bombay qu'un petit scotch au dessus
c'est un morceau spectaculaire ses
banques si tu penses pas de caisse qui y
en a
aura pas même ses excellents chasser
l'intérieur de la grèce veut voir que la
voie est bien cuit tout les ingrédients
sont bien mélanger soso whisky dessous
comme ça c'est plutôt survit
le goût de foi est très léger c'est pas
du tout eu comme comme google on peut
penser nous j'aime bien la petite
texture que dans l'avoine aussi l'ennemi
il croque en moelleux c'est d'y ajouter
un la texture des abats a vraiment
délicieux chef merci beaucoup et ça m'a
fait plaisir très heureuse
[Musique]